good evening
and welcome to this eastern area
planning committee meeting on wednesday
the 26th of may
2021 can everybody hear me
yes lovely my name is councillor vanessa
bell and i'm the chairman of this
committee
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run
through members the set up for the
meeting has been designed to mitigate
the covid
therefore can i ask all presents to work
to the protocols agreed at council on
29th april 2021 in the interest of
member and
office of safety we're streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak
and please bear with me because it is
quite difficult to see with the screens
so wave about if you need to
i will then invite you to speak at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask
or shout put your advisor on and speak
clearly
members whatever you feel most
comfortable with because i know it is
challenging with this
mask visor business please reference a
page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers keep your contributions
as clear and concise as possible please
ensure your microphones remain
off when not speaking now members i do
need to point out that the fire exit
tonight is this door here so whereas we
would
usually follow the running man we'll be
going out this way tonight
i don't believe there are any fire
drills planned so if the alarm goes off
it will be a real fire so please leave
the chamber
and item number two apologies for
absence
um apologies for absence have been
received from councillors
r g boyce this is p a channel
rpf juric and n schemes
gender item number three minutes of the
14th april 2021
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on 14th of april 2021
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true
and accurate record why so moved
madam chairman i'd like to comment on
one brief item on page 8.
there was a brief discussion and at the
councillor stamp mentioned she had a
boat on the site and paid for it
then left the meeting thank you
thank you council hell is that
thank you thank you
so well did i have a second a minute
council hell
yes thank you um
do we can we agree those by cent members
or do we need to take
votes
thank you item 4
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disposable
pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive as the current conduct
remembers
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting
members does anyone wish to declare
cancer yes chairman
i know the applicant because it's a
counsellor
on a journey of item six and i'm also an
essex county councillor
thank you very much thank you council
staff i
can advise that a gender item six has
been withdrawn
oh ok thank you
thank you very much so that brings us on
to agenda item number 5
20 slash 03. oh 1 3 4
7 fql varnish road
mainland which can be found on pages 11
to 20.
so please note that the members update
in relation to this application has been
circulated throughout the meeting
so if i put hands over to the table
first to present the report please
thank you
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a fenced enclosure
to provide an all-weather surface area
for exercising horses owned by the
applicants
it should be noted that works on site
commenced in september 2020
please note the members update with two
further letters of objection
this is the location plan showing these
sites outlined in red
this is the block plan showing the host
dwelling on the western side
and the development to the east the
development is located in the
northeastern corner and would
measure 21.2 meters by 40 meters
development would be boarded by a timber
post and rail fence measuring
1.3 meters high
this is the elevation plan showing the
timber fence surrounding the development
here are some photographs of the site
view
one is from the north west and you can
see the development is not visible as
it's shielded
by vegetation view two
is taken from steeple road to the north
and again
shows that it's not visible
u3 is also taken from the road to the
north
and the development is shielded by the
barn
u4 is taken from the east adjacent to
the development and you can
just see it in the corner of the photo
and view five and six are taken from the
west facing towards the development
the proposed development would not cause
harm to the character and appearance of
the area
furthermore subject to conditions it's
not considered that the proposal would
result in material harm
to the immunity of neighbouring
occupiers and nor would it impact on
highway safety
the application is therefore recommended
for approval thank you chairman
thank you for stopping first um
i'm talking to myself um do any other
offices with any other officers like to
add anything
to uh stable nurse presentation no
thank you okay um
members i now open the debate and invite
you to put any questions or make any
comments you have on the report council
thank you madam chairman um this is
really a retrospective planning
application
because most of the work's already been
done uh
trees apparently being torn out and all
sorts of things have happened on this
site
um it was sent to the enforcement
officer
some time ago and nothing really
happened and there's a
appeal waiting on a lawful development
certificate as well
so i'd like to ask the officers what
they think about that
and why they didn't do something about
it beforehand thank you
thank you chairman um it's accept the
point of planning the
fact that an application may be
retrospective it should not be a
determined factor in
when coming to a recommendation decision
of an application
and the planning system allows for
explicitly within us paragraph 73a i
think it is
allows for planned applications to be
submitted to regularized breaches
planning control
therefore no comment in relation to that
in the merits of this application
function
thank you mr later sat answer your
question
thank you thank you um many other
members wish to uh
to comment on this application
no i don't see any hands so um
well i would move to
i propose that the um i propose that we
agree the officer's
uh recommendation do i have a secondary
counselor bill thank you members uh
can we agree that by a sense or do we
have to
require a recorded vote recorded vote
plan
do i have a center for that
council messenger thank you
if
um can you please stay clearly or
against our abstain starting with
council passenger
four council field
or
council helm abstain
counter hall
thank you chairman that's four for the
application
none against two abstentions so
uh that is carried as per officer
recommendation
thank you as stated previously item six
land north of rivers league hipsters
chase has been
withdrawn by the applicants so
we move on to agenda item seven
rosemary manga chain spurn
this can be found on pages 37-54
so it was key if you could
give you a couple of moments to get
yourself ready
that's fine we do have one public
participant for this planning
application
so once was keen as presented
we will move to the theater
thank you
the applicant is applied for commission
for an annex
used by the current signed
shout if you need
the applicant has applied permission
from annex to used by the applicant's
son
daughter-in-law the applicant was stated
at the building
the applicant has applied for permission
for an annex to be used by the
applicant's son
or daughter-in-law the applicant has
stated that the building will be
occupied independently to the main
dwelling
by the applicant's son and there will be
no functional link to the main drawing
just like a functional link showing the
development in the main house the
application
of the development cannot be considered
as an annex and must be assessed if
needed wedding
this is a location plan shown a proposed
site outlanding red
this is a proposed block plan showing
the site with the main dwelling
and the existing garage to the east of
the barn and the proposed development
due to the position of the barn the
windows and doors in the sudden
elevation
of the bar would result in direct
overlooking
of the main dwelling
these are the existing elevations
these are the proposed elevations
this is the existing floor plan
and this is the proposed floor plan
a scheme was previously refused at this
site for a similar development
full of for the following reasons the
post scheme failed to demonstrate
that development would amount to the
annex accommodation
being ancillary to the main drawing the
development was outside the settlement
boundary
and the absence of section 106 to secure
iran's contribution
these are the photos of the site shown
in the barn subject to the current
application
the application is recommended for
refusal as the scheme failed to
demonstrate that the development would
amount to an annex accommodation
that would be used and siri to the main
dwelling
it is noted that it would be considered
reasonable it would not be considered
reasonable or necessary to condition
development to be used and serious named
ready as it could
not be considered as ancillary
development due to level accommodation
provided
it's located its location within the
site
and that it will be occupied
independently to the existing dwelling
on the site
it's therefore considered a condition in
regards to the building being used and
severely to remain dwelling
would not meet the six tests as set out
within the plain practice guidance and
the national planning personal framework
and therefore cannot be included the
proposed development
would therefore be unacceptable being
unacceptable visual impacts on the
countryside
are harmful to the level of overlooking
and the space of the existing dwelling
and provide a shortfall in car parking
and a lack of litigation
in relation to rams thank you chad thank
you
ms king so um if i
could ask miss taverner to
read out your submission please and may
i remind you that you're allocated
two minutes for public speaking in
accordance with the scheme
so if you could start the timer please
miss key okay i believe it will come up
on the screen right
now ready ready yeah from now please
thank you oh thank you
um i would just like to put that
straight but
the reason we're asking for this because
like one of my sons has become
homeless because he was renting a house
during the lockdown and
it was sold so him and his family had to
move out
as i had the accommodation and we made
arrangements
for my other son and his wife to just
share the five bedrooms basically
the annex is there it has no vision
impact on anybody it's
quite an attractive building it will
extend
1.5 metres over the boundary of
sustainable development
which i don't think would matter it has
no impact on anybody at all
visually and the next door neighbors are
quite happy with
the development there is services are
going to be totally shared by the main
house
there is an access path from the
east to the west past my house
and all the services as i said will be
there there are parking
car parking spaces for about eight to
ten cars
so there's absolutely no issue as far as
parking is concerned
and it will also provide special housing
needs for me
because i'm getting up
thank you very much mrs thank you
so um any any other officers like to
comment before we open the floor
no members i now open the debate and
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments you have on the report
remembers
i'll speak thank you yeah
i think it's no secret that i always
have voice concerns that we don't have a
policy about
alexis and i also understand that it
maybe isn't
joined and connected so it could be
classed or will be classed
as a separate wedding and i know i
always get told off you shouldn't put
emotion into it
but i think on this occasion i don't
agree with the officers
that it is altering the character of the
area
i think if anybody knows where this is
you will
notice that there's been a substantial
change to development and the character
of that area
anyway i am cautious about whether i
will
agree to support the officer's
recommendation or not still at this
stage so i have got an open mind
but i i do feel that we need to
actually have more dialogue with people
i mean i think this is going to be a
bigger issue following covid anyway and
i think this authority
and our authorities are going to have to
re-adjust and realign
we know that the landlord's protection
is ending and i think we're going to
have a serious housing crisis now i know
mr lee is going to jump in in a minute
and say council stand they are not
planning reasons
and maybe they aren't but i do feel very
strongly
that we have got to look after our
residents
and i'm mindful that if we do grant a
separate dwelling it opens the foot gate
so as i said i
i don't agree with the officers that
it's changing the character
the next door neighbor hasn't
disapproved there's already
dwelling there there's nothing wrong
with it they just want to extend it
to accommodate a family member and and
i think the applicant is true no
disrespect and please don't sue me if
she said it herself she's getting older
and she might need that support
which we all may do and i would love to
have an annex in my house for my mother
which is sadly where it happened because
she's too far
gone with dementia now but i mean it
would be i think we need to look at that
so that's all i've got to say at this
stage i know they're not grabbing
planning reasons
because i haven't gone pre-determined
and with planning reasons
thank you madam chairman um this is all
too common where
families want to live together and extra
accommodation and things like this
and this is going to go on and on and on
because no one can afford a house now
they're too blue
sexist sorry
but they are you just can't i mean
everyone says oh you can buy
share buy and all the rest of it you
can't get on that market
so i think this is a very good idea and
i would recommend against the officer's
recommendation
thank you so um
yes so do if do any other members
mr lee yeah thank you um
i was just agreeing with them really
because looking after my parents myself
and
lots of elderly people we need to be
looking after our families
so i support it wholeheartedly thank you
council hall mr laina thank you chairman
um
i'm probably going to start with a thing
that members have heard me say a hundred
times if not more you know we are here
to determine applications according to
the development plan unless material
considerations
indicate otherwise and by law the
starting point needs to be
our policies um cancer stamps said we
don't have a policy but we do have an
spd which deals with matters such as
this and you know the officer paul
in paragraph 5.1.4 deals with that and
goes through
latterly the various considerations and
you know we've explained
why we think it falls foul various
points within the seven
criteria and if members want a bit more
clarity than i can get
ms king's taking through that as the
case officer
um so you know the policy there is a
policy and that should be the
consideration
um where we start from i think there's a
couple other points um can't stand made
a potential
harm in future either because of kobe or
because of uh changes in the
housing act and legislation and
those things could become material
considerations in the future but
planning his has to be based on evidence
and the fear of changing the future
is not evidence and we should not be
based in planning application
determination of applications on
things that we may feel which should be
on evidence and policy so
those matters should you know should be
parked when it comes to termination of
an application
and that just anything goes on to the
material situation the point about the
applicant getting older and this
can't stand i think it was said yeah
we're all getting older but that's the
point
the fact that somebody's getting older
is not special it's not very special
circumstances when it comes to personal
circumstances case law is clear
that it is very special circumstances
and
the applicant has actually pretty much
explained in the
her pres of two minutes that it isn't
going to be used and it's why there may
be
certain shared services it's going to be
a separate dwelling and
an approach such as this would be a very
dangerous precedent to set for members
because
for the council because agents will use
decisions we make against us from any
decision whether it's here at committee
or it's delegated
will be used against it it doesn't
matter it's in the southeast north west
central
or anywhere these they're the decisions
of the council
and statements such as you know we
should be allowing people to build
basically annexes
if there's space because it's not going
to have harm when
the applicant has actually indicated
that it won't be an annex it is a
separate dwelling
it's a very very dangerous present
because basically what we're saying is
we're allowing
separate dwellings if you have relatives
you know
as i said getting older or having
children and having space and then
leaving a home
are not what the eyes lord be considered
very special circumstances we all have
personal circumstances
and there's a need to hit and pass a
higher threshold than that
and that is something that members
should be very conscious of when looking
at this application
um the only other point is i think
council stamps said about it being an
extension to the dwelling it's not
for clarity and if ms king can just
explain that just so
show actually what the development is
you said you said extension but you
might have meant
because it's not connected no it's not
that's why that's what i just went
clarity so
yeah sorry check uh chairman but yeah so
he can't stand as well yeah i thought we
said it was extension
um might can't say well maybe i just
i've heard that one but yeah i think
that's everything
thanks thank you missy unfortunately mrs
taverner i'm
not able to learn to come back so i
apologize
for that thank you
members counselor stamp can we have uh
mr lee said about
the case officer giving us clarity on
5.1.4 can we have that
thank you so
the council has a document that's a
special housing needs spd
and if a person applies for an annex
that annex needs to adhere to the seven
different criteria within that section
of the spd
which is then run through in section
5.1.5
within the report so the first
requirement is that it's subservient
to the main dwelling and the second
requirement is it has a functional link
with the main dwelling so the occupant
would be dependent
on the relatives at the main dwelling
the third one would be that it's within
the same ownership
and the fourth one being within the
cursor and showed access
and that it could be transferred back
into an integral part of the main
dwelling
at a later date when the annex is no
longer required
um point six of the std states that
there should be no separate boundary or
subdivision
and point seven says it should have
adequate parking to meet the needs of
both the annex
and the main dwelling so these are the
considerations that we have to take into
account
when assessing these types of
applications
and if they fall short on any of those
seven points
then it doesn't meet the criteria for
that
but for being annex so as you can see in
the report it has fallen short on
several of those elements thank you
thank you
thank you ms kane does that clarify no
no i'm
chairman it doesn't because i'd like it
and maybe being a little bit dense but
which ones does it fall short on because
the only one i can see that it falls
short on
is that it doesn't have a functional
link with the main dwelling
which is
um the actual
you know to certainly it doesn't it's a
moot point how many
it falls down on because those are the
points that are required for it to meet
the policy
um if you think that
the shortfall in one is not equal two or
three or half man is no exception
on balance doesn't cause harm is a
different matter but the policy
doesn't say it it can only estimate
above five or
four or whatever it's required to meet
all of them for it to be
considered acceptable in policy terms um
ms king's report obviously deals with it
in detail and 5.1.5 explains our
the actual impact on the character and
the distance etcetera is dealt with
further below in the design section and
whether it can be read as subservient
um ration to criteria two
you know the applicant is acknowledging
correspondence it be
by separately by the son and wife who
work you know it's not dependent on the
dwelling which is a very important point
um it they it will be you
you know it will be occupied as a normal
dwelling you know if
no different to if you live next door to
your parents rather than having a
symbiotic um ancillary relationship that
needs to be for it to be an annex
not just um a close relationship you
know
we've all know people that maybe have
moved out their parents and still have a
very close relationship with them
um and you know there is a difference
you know and that that's what
you have to consider um
it goes on to obviously discuss points
five and six in
paragraph 5.1.7
and we've raised there's that paragraph
says existing outbuilding will form
will form part of the annex whilst the
building is detached from the main build
dwelling it's possible for the
outbuilding to be used in relation to
the dreading in the user's annex
ceased ies storage room or gardening
however given the concerns relating to
exciting and separation
and boundary treatment already there is
concern that is unlikely to
occur and the future occupation may not
accord with five or six because of the
distance and the physical relationship
between the two properties um yeah
we've acknowledged the parking can be
met but yeah so
the report highlights a number of points
more than just one that where officers
consider there is conflict with the
criteria
and as i said it's not a point about
whether or not it's only
one or the other thank you thank you mr
lee council stamp then cancer hell
hopefully
i'll go i'll give way for you to go
answer hell thank you madam chairman um
this annex is connected to the house via
drains
water supply and electricity supply so
there is a connection there thank you
and oh and we haven't got a five year
housing supply have we thank you thank
you council help kazakhstan
um yeah thank you i totally take on lord
everything mr lee has said
and but um even in my short time of
attending southeast planning meetings i
think councillor helm i was hoping
cancer dewitt would be able to come
because i can remember
a discussion where there was one that
was wasn't subservient
and it was approved i think it was
tillingham him or bradwell and it was
down the garden
uh and that was approved and i couldn't
believe that was approved because it's
similar to what we're talking about here
and i think there's more than that
councillor helm that has been approved i
know that there's something bernamon
crouch that were annexes and at the
bottom of the garden they're not joined
together by glass building or anything
or whatever
i totally take on board what mr lee's
saying and i totally understand it could
set a precedent
and i think we members we need to be
very mindful of this
but there has been it's not case law but
there has been
precedence set in this district where
separate dwellings have been
uh granted in their back gardens whether
it be a you know a long garden or not
i think it's called the nut patch or nut
house where the
the annex was it's on the malden road at
the top uh where that one there was one
at the vic
near the vicarage on church road that
was an annex that was
subs that wasn't subservient to the
actual main dwelling
that was approved on appeal and so i i
do think there is
precedence set um especially in burnham
and i think tillingham and bradwell and
thank you councillor helm for supporting
me on that so he was at that
just like to clarify i mean the word
connect if
are we talking about connecting has to
be connected by some sort of
glass walkway or something or if it
shares the same immunities which
i believe it does is that not a
connection is
we just clarify that okay
mr thank you chairman um for essentially
i was going to come on to that point
because
um the reference to physical connection
is actually
through the old local plan policy it's
not the current policy the current
policy does allow for
structures to be separate from the main
dwelling and
um if i'm 100 honest i was never
particularly keen on how old quality
when i started because i did think it
was
i didn't think it's reasonable to say it
it had to be physically attached i don't
have a
planning principle problem with the idea
of a detached air mechanics
but i have concerns about the fact that
this is not
in my eyes legally and annex they are
not putting forward an ancillary
development and i'm very worried that to
be honest that the
statements that i've heard tonight are
that if an applicant wants to build a
house in their garden for their relative
that is policy compliant that is an
acceptance for the council
so i think if members are going to put
forward like we have had a
approach to be approved there needs to
be a reason for approval
and i just would like to get members to
be very careful on how they work this
because
this will be a material consideration in
the termination of any future
applications
and i think it's very dangerous just to
reference two appeals
that have happened within the district
without actually
i've off the cuff i don't know what they
are i can't comment about the planning
history i can't talk about the site
specifics and
while obviously an annex being focused
with dwelling on an expert that separate
is a material consideration without any
detail to be able to actually
formally compare them and actually do a
planning judgment
correlation i would be very reluctant to
give them any demand for weight and
determination but
you know i'm quite worried about the
ability for us to defend certain
applications as a council from what's
been said actually
thank you councilman
again i mean it seems to be in the
wording i think the the lady who put her
case
perhaps used unfortunate words i think
she was very honest
and i think perhaps she said something
that made you feel as though
it wasn't going to be what she is
planning to do
i think we have some points covered
which we have an attachment that shares
immunities
i think mr lee has admitted that we can
actually
provide the parking and i don't know if
it
has separate boundaries or not i don't
think it does so
which points are we not happy with
exactly
thank you chairman um for one point
i'd come back what i was supposed to say
the first time i forgot sorry about that
and
i'm getting excited just being out the
house
the of the point about shared facilities
and something
for clarity we have had and lost appeals
where
um applicants have shown that for local
events difficult while it's got shared
facilities they
had electricity sewers etc that they've
had somebody else living in it and
although it was great commissioners and
annex they were able to prove
either four years slash tenants if there
was a condition that it had been a
breach so
things such as shared facilities are not
having their own electricity bill
are not things that will class this as
an annex
in the big picture but it won't stop it
being used as an independent dwelling
um you know it's how it's planning to be
used and
the applicant's been clear that it's for
their their son and daughter that
are not to having a symbol articulate an
ancillary relationship the
correspondence i think
ms king might be able to take us through
that a little bit more if i give a bit
of a warning just to confirm some of the
correspondence with that i think it's
never support reference to it
but um yeah but i just
but so i'll go back i'll see in relation
to the
point that counts the buttons just
raised um
the policy has said it does say about
functional link and it says that are you
the occupants
dependent relatives that's a key point
dependent relatives not just relatives
um or or they're employed in the main
dwelling so
just the functional link isn't about
physical structure or anything it's
about
how it would actually react
in relation so i don't know what the
second point was cancer derived would
you like to
remind me what was the query second part
of the query sorry um yeah
no it was just you know it seems as
though we've covered off some of these
sort of planning
issues that you mentioned the five the
five points and i just wondered exactly
which which were the other two we seemed
to sort of got
three
i think one was about the character and
i think it was the story yeah which
obviously raised concern in relation to
the character
um because of the distance etcetera
see we've raised concerns about the
whether it's a dependent
resident because we've been advised
basically that it isn't
so there won't be a functional link to
the main dwellings that's the first two
the main ownership we've got no issue at
the moment with that
so things can change in the future but
that's a separate matter so that's not a
mature consideration
um said vehicular access is fine
um and i think there's an issue in
relation to
sort of just move down views as a later
date for an integral part of the main
dwelling
um because of the physical relationship
and the boundaries
that one's a bit more of a balanced
argument because it could be used as a
garden room but
whether would that would actually would
be what would happen is a different
questions that's
there's concerns rather than clear
conflict with that point
um there is certain physical
relationship that would already
facilitate a subdivision
and we think that car parking's fine
thank you thank you
council messenger so we're pretty much
there in as i mean we're sort of arguing
the tops about this one
i mean in a way i mean is is it
we're as close to saying we could
approve it as much as we're
close to saying we can refuse it isn't
it correct chairman professionally no
it's not an annex the occupiers are not
going to use the property as an annex
and that's
the stumbling block in my professional
point is that
you know it is it's basically a separate
dwelling in the garden
for one of the better phrases that's how
the applicant's been clearly planning to
use it
i'll come to you in a moment but i
suppose the question that i have in my
mind
is if this application were the other
way around and the applicant's son and
daughter were in the main house and the
proposed annex was for the applicant
would we be viewing this differently
um you know i'm gonna say we can't work
in guesstimates and assumptions but what
i would say is
it needs to be a dependent relative
so at the moment you know i don't know
anything about the applicant to comment
on
whether or not but on the sim on the
assumption that
because because on the assumption that
the
the argument hasn't been put forward
that these this is needed to support the
upper parts of the main dwelling
there's not a need for these people to
move in this carers point of view phrase
that argument hasn't been put foot to
the council
so on that basis i don't think that
would be a difference because
it would still be an independent
dwelling for an older person
rather than being an annexed steel but
that's based on
no fact just an assumption and i don't
like doing that
committee thank you thank you mr lay
councillor stan
chairman i'm really a little bit
exasperated because what we're actually
maybe intimating insinuating here that
if the applicant
told phipps yeah we may grant it because
it's based on a fibbing
lie basically and i've sat at
applications where um
planning meetings where applications has
been approved and they've said that they
want it for a relative
and they've got something and then it's
been sold quite quickly afterwards
because they've managed to do what they
wanted to do contrary to what we were
told
and have been told when we've been at
this meeting
and i know mr lee is going to say to me
cancer stanford you can't base it on
that
but i actually welcome people who
actually tell the truth when they come
to committees and speak to us
as members and as officers i i feel
quite strongly that we
they shouldn't be penalized and i can
see it that the
young people are dependent in some ways
because otherwise they're going to be
homeless
so i think there is a dependent link
here and it could be classed as tenuous
and
and i'm sure i'm going to get headlines
everywhere moulding district council
leaders done this or whatever
but i think there is a link here and i i
think that
you know they they are dependent they're
dependent
because they've been kicked out they've
got nowhere to live so they've gone back
home
and the the parents are trying to do the
best for them and i think it could be
um that they could then look after their
parents as the parents
get in their dotage i think the saying
is and
is there any way that we can meet with
the applicant
to try and make sure to try and
accommodate this because
i feel with cats and bassinger the same
we're not too far away
i think it can be approved in some
some shape or form that this annex could
be approved
um for them to live in can that not be
done mr lee
mr lee do you want to come back then
i'll go to council hell
chairman from the information in front
of us um
i don't see how it could be i could
enter into a pre-app with his
applications reviews and
discuss that um
the you know the issue is that if
members consider that the policy and
that then becomes the council decision
that
if it's a relative and you know it
cheaper point of about phrase to build a
house for them that meets the special
requirements because somebody one day
may need care that also meets
special requirements you know we are
very much watering down our policy
and we are very much allowing any
dwelling
remembering that this policy is
much more lenient on things such as car
parking much more lenient things such as
amenities face much more lenient on many
factors that
if we are to take a very very low bar on
certain aspects of that policy
it will make us very difficult to stop
a lot of dwellings within the district
for one of a better phrase not to think
and these are dwellings that won't
because they're not dwellings according
to our policy
will not provide um not me anything
towards the hat five-year land supply
and will not um because of the scale
and the numbers we could done we
wouldn't get any nhs confusion education
contribution so
i think it's it's a very dangerous
position is to water down the policy
with the arguments i've heard tonight
that's all i can say
thank you mr lee council
thank you madam chairman can mr lee not
uh limit this by condition so it cannot
be used for anything else but this
to help you so when we go to appeal on
anything else you're protected
chairman um professionally i don't think
a conditional
invasion of an act would be with the
ultraviolet the applicant's clear that
it's not
an ancillary relationship it is not a
dependent relationship
it's just a family property and actually
an imposition invocation to it annex i
think
would be ultra virus i think members are
better off considering it's a new
dwelling rather than as an annex if they
would
and you know arguably but even that i
still think we've been in a ridiculously
dangerous position because we haven't
looked at i mean space remnants of the
car but we have actually looked at those
matters and there are problems in
relation to car parking if you did look
into separate dwelling
but any condition in relation to an
annex i think potentially would be
ultraviolet
because it is not an annex and we can't
put on a condition that isn't reasonable
gentlemen the actual application
says extension to existing brick plinth
timber frame barn to provide one bedroom
ancillary granny annex
for extended family that's what the
application says
not a separate dwelling so i'm a little
bit confused and
the other bit about not getting any
contributions
please don't get me started because i
can rattle off many housing
single dwellings or fives and sixties
where this council hasn't
had any contributions and i think it is
real shame that we are not supporting
this application in the fact that it's a
genuine
need and if for the work it's a crime
for help they are going to be homeless
and yes okay it's a dangerous precedent
but i've also sat at
planning applications where members and
officers
maybe officers maybe not members think
that jones precedence has been set
um i think we could go around the houses
all day on this
and i think we're going to struggle to
find out because mr lee is going to turn
around and say we need a reason for
approval
and i know he's going to give us a tough
time so i think we need to just
can we have a couple of minutes to think
about unless somebody else wants to
speak this
just for clarity my professional advice
would be the fact the applicants will be
or
the applicant children be homeless is
not a material consideration
determination of any planning
application
however harsh that may sound in the eyes
of the law that is not the material
situation for the termination of planned
application we're here to determine
according to the development plan
not in accordance with our hearts thank
you chairman
thank you
so members i think we do as councillor
sam said we could go round and round in
circles for the rest of the night on
this so members i'm going to move to if
i would unless anybody else
counselor b or sorry thank you supposing
this application didn't say anything
about annex and was just put forward as
a solitary application for a new
building there
how would we do it
dude chairman um we have actually
assessed that in the report because we
don't consider it full within the
definition of annex so and we've found a
number of
refusal in relation to
uh just so if i get down to the bottom
you'll see it's uh dwelling in a remote
location obviously urbanization of the
site you know sort of standard points in
relation to a dwelling in this
location uh
[Music]
overlooking by the relationship between
the building if it was
you know a separate dwelling
[Music]
and there wouldn't be enough car parking
for it and it would need rams which i'm
sure they'd be able to overcome
um the other can i just quickly come
back on one other point about
because i said this councillor stamps
put in relation to
what is put on the description that
isn't legally binding as the man-o-man
case law
states um you can't find an application
by its description
you have to be able to find it by
conditions and plans etcetera
so the fact that it would say on it it's
an annex if it
isn't actually an annex it's an
irrelevant point
thank you thank you council
chairman i mean i take on board what mr
lee's just maybe said but it's a bit
late in the day throwing that in i think
as members
we would look always a proposal to see
what the proposal was and i'll be guided
by you because you are the chief
planning
gentleman but i mean we have to be
guided by what's on the report
and it does say quite clearly extension
to existing building
and did it for ancillary granny on next
for the extended family
now i think that's a debate for planning
training that you can
give us a delay today but looking at the
reasons for refusal
um madam chair i mean
i don't particularly agree with the
reasons for refusal so
with maybe some assistance from
assistance from the other members
we if we are still going to carry on
with the vote that was
raised proposed by councillor helm and i
don't i don't agree
with the fact that it changes the the
area of the character character of the
area and the
unacceptable impacts on the countryside
and so that's two
two reasons which i don't agree and i
don't know whether members agree with me
or not thank you
thank you members i'm going to move to
vote now
on councillor helm's proposal
we need reason for approval before we go
to them do we have reason for approval
we should approve it is based on little
two at number two
i don't think it does result
intensification of residential
development and substantially
substantially alter the character of the
area and i don't believe it will have an
unacceptable visual impact on the
countryside through the urbanization
i don't i don't agree with that at all
so i don't know what policy that is
because i haven't brought my ldp with me
and i haven't pre-determined
so and the applicant
i think it is subservient to the main
dwelling
which well maybe members and you don't
agree with me i don't know members
but i i think i think on those policies
alone
it's one of the most balanced that's
been done
so difficult balance ones i think on the
on the points that you've mentioned
cancer staff mr lee can i come to you
yeah through your challenges for clarity
it wouldn't be the tilted balance in
this instance because it's not a new
dwelling what members are saying
so just no no no just for clarity it's
one of the things that someone could use
it again i know you didn't you know it's
the clarity um
but
there obviously is a certain level of
subjectivity to certain points about
whether it's observant whether it's
impacts on
character to the area
i am
struggling with how every other
applicant wouldn't be able to use the
argument that
farms in their gardens can be converted
where you know
for an annex because there isn't
additionality and
you know we really need to see what are
the differences here to any other one so
i think we need to have a more
expansion on that to give better clarity
to any member because the point of the
reason approval is that any member of
public should be able to understand why
members have come to a clear
different conclusion to the officers
obviously when there's
uh officers report they've got the whole
report so a member of public should be
able to
clearly understand what the members
thought what was different so and
see we don't need detailed policies so
don't worry about that counselor stamp
but
you need enough expansion so and i would
say to protect the council that we can
clearly
explain why this is different to another
one because otherwise we will have these
use against us that appeal
and applications thank you thank you
chairman well i'm afraid i'm going to
come back at mr lee with what he came
back at me for about not having the
actual
planning um appeal cases i cannot
remember the tillingham one
of the bradwell one where the separate
dwelling in the garden was
was approved and i think those reasons
maybe could be cited at this application
manager i'm not being difficult i'm
trying to find the actual reason i don't
know off the top of my head
what they were but that was approved so
those reasons i feel would be very
similar to these reasons but i don't
know what they are mr lee
that was my thought council staff
actually that it would be useful to know
what those reasons were
councillor bassinger just just think
that we have sort of established that
there is a link
and this building is subservient because
it shares the amenities
with the main house and i think if it
was a separate if it was a barn at the
bottom of the garden
and it wasn't sharing those amenities
and i think we could say it was just a
stand-alone building but
because this is sharing the electricity
the water the sewage
it certainly is linked i also think that
we've managed to mitigate the parking
issue which i think mr lee has agreed
that
we would be able to overcome that um as
far as the access is also concerned i
presume there is only one access
to the buildings that
yes that is correct there's only one
access uh there is a door to the front
but there is also
um doors that would be installed in the
northern elevation what i was actually
referring to is actually
the sort of driveway entering into the
area yes there's one there's a driveway
in front of the garage and then there's
another parking space in front of the
house
and and there's been no sort of um
application to
open up another entrance or anything
like that
not under this application so it again i
think we've sort of established
that both both parts of this
you know the main house and and the
annex let's say
we'll be sharing the same drive so
there's i think it's pretty much
sort of a leak that we can say exists
there we have the parking
it certainly doesn't seem to alter the
character of the air in fact
it may have been proven
and so we're sort of left with them
relationship between um
the lady and her son you know are they
dependent are they not dependent i don't
know i mean
i think there is a dependency children
always dependent upon their parents for
all sorts of things they never seem to
go away mine don't
so and i think you know if if if i was
in that position you know
my children certainly would be dependent
and i am dependent on them we are a
family we're dependents
you know they're my we are family we
depend on each other so and i think
in this case in particular we certainly
do have
you know a dependency issue where there
is a young couple that
you know the obviously overcrowding i
presume in the house and that's why they
need their they need a bit more space
and i think
you know this that's a valid a valid
dependency you know
they're unable to buy somewhere and so
um they are dependent upon their parents
and uh would that do mr lee in any way
[Laughter]
you've basically said yeah the banker
mum and dad means you can build a house
in your garden so yeah please don't use
that members please do not yet
yeah i'm sorry that's yeah that would
really water down the policy that reason
for approval um
yeah that would be my advice members
would you know be conscious of that
because
it was yeah this is this is the issue
you know there is a policy requirement
and
the application isn't meeting that
threshold on that point and it's very
hard for us as officers to give advice
on that point when
our professional opinion is is
substantially short of the requirement
the end of the day decision is in
members it's in your gift
it's your responsibility to come up with
a reason for approval i can only provide
advice but
um i i'm struggling to tell you i
legally i can't help anywhere near as
much on a reason for approval anyway
than i can a reason for refusal
that's in the case law that's clear but
um and i do try and help where i can but
you know expected that i am struggling
to be able to provide
any advice in this instance my personal
opinion thank you
i think i think in all seriousness we
are having a bit of a giggle which is
brilliant
but council messenger has raised some
very valid points
if you're looking at the reasons for
refusals if you want to go down them one
by one it's very serious the
the reason for reviews or one of them is
parking that's been addressed
yes yeah the reason for refusal um
was well i forgot what you were the ones
were there's loads of them so the
proposed development by reason of
location and the resultant
intensification
which is what i said of residential
development i don't agree with so i
think that is not a reason for refusal
and i know you said that's
what's the word subjective for you
chairman just
not trying if members consider it's an
annex reasons two down just disappear
anyway
right okay you know okay the reasons to
and beyond about the council's
consideration is a separate dwelling
so for clarity if members do consider
it's an annex
they would only have to talk to that
reason for refusal
so can the others fall away for clarity
so i
don't wanna yeah it might be dense
chairs so
what am i looking at so i'm looking at
reason one am i only
yeah three chairman obviously the count
the applicant has submitted an
application as an annex we've looked at
it as in our policy and for various
reasons do not consider it falls under
the annex therefore we the first reason
for refusal talks
to that issue because it's not an annex
we can and we consider it to be a
separate dwelling
and we consider it can't be an annex
we've then looked at it
as in is it acceptable to have a
dwelling in that site if members
consider it to be an annex
reasons refusal two through two i'm
going to say five off the top of the
head
fall away it's only reason one which is
about the annex and the shortfalls
with the policy so that would be the
only one that members would need to talk
to in their reason for approval
members i would like to move a
proposal to an annex
and can we go to the vote please
we we can i think can we see
we need the reason for approval we
haven't we haven't got one yet so
someone needs to
check the whoever's put it forward needs
to put forward their reason for approval
counselor helm i believe your reason for
approval was that we do believe it is we
do see it as an annex
is that the case is that sufficiently
chairman we we don't see that it does
fail to integrate with the shared and
communal garden area
we think it is part of the same space
yes it isn't separated by a boundary or
anything
so i i think to to help councillor help
who's helping us as well
you know it isn't a division of an
immediate space to the southern boundary
so to speak
i i don't see it is a division
personally
and i just don't agree with
the reason for reviews on number one
sorry mr lee
i don't agree with it so my
understanding of where we are members
is that we are recommending approval so
we're recommending that we go against
the officer's recommendation
on the grounds that we do accept that
this is an annex
is that correct and links
sharing just a little bit of help which
you know i said i can't do a slight
little bit with
approval you know
but i do try and do what i can do um
obviously if members can
if to plan their eyes or for what you
know plan
plan or leave to face what you're saying
i would say that you're trying
to imply that you consider that
the proposal does meet the requirements
of the spd you know all seven points as
i've said i've
got some significant concerns about that
but if that's what members
consider that's up to them
point of clarity does it i thought we
established you don't have to have all
seven points
i didn't think that's what the officer
said
well we do think it meets ourselves we
do
members so counselor bill before i go to
the boat
um been here for many many years and i
know
that over a period of time we've had
many applications for annexes and
everything else and then
sometime later they've been separated
and sold off etc
can we put something in there to create
a more substantial one
i don't believe we can come here
so we can do that you would still end up
in theory
but that would give some protection so
um
council helm is that an amendment to
your proposal i'm quite acceptable
because i didn't ask him if he had
members can if they wish but i would
advise we don't could be ultraviolets
but
if members consider that it was an annex
and it totally meets the requirement
then they can impose that condition
whether or not if the applicant was ever
to appeal it
it would be found to be flawed as a
separate conversation but if members
think it meets the seven
criteria they can but as officers
we don't think it does we wouldn't
encourage that but we wouldn't encourage
the
commission being granted thank you thank
you mr lady members we are saying
that is what we think yes
so we will then take a vote on
councillor hell's proposal
oh mr lee clarity chairman are you
delegating
the formation of all the conditions to
operators to a great uh consultation
with yourself
you need to do that as well before yeah
absolutely so
um i think we have a proposal which is
that we
um support the application of the
application
and then for mr lee to consult with
myself regarding language conditions
members are we able to agree that by
sent or do we wish to have a recorded
vote
that's free and we're happy to agree
that by a sense
i agree i believe we are
so thank you very much members that is
agreed
so contrary to the officer's
recommendation
that application is approved mr lee
thank you very much for your support on
that your words of wisdom
members thank you very much for your
your input
on that so brings me on to agenda
item eight any other items of business
that
the chairman of the community decides
and i have
none members so thank you again for your
contribution this evening and i now draw
the meeting to
close at i believe 8 31
p.m